so elections can go sour and lots of
ways I mean somebody might try to
manipulate the elections if they're on
the gift the only results are on the
computer someone could manipulate the
computer somehow so for that reason I
like to have elections based on paper
ballots paper ones are less open to
manipulation yeah a computer a
particularly one that's might be
connected to the Internet is terribly
vulnerable
somebody's counted the paper ballots and
announced the result but you might still
be a bit skeptical you should be
skeptical right I mean this is important
to them
well the loser will be skeptical anyway
for sure and so you want to process the
post-election audit is what we call it
for really convincing the news that the
result the announced result is the right
result and so there's lots of techniques
for that I can describe one of them that
I like to you but post election know
that it takes the pile of cast paper
ballots and does a statistical sample to
see if the outcome is consistent yeah if
you have an election with a million
voters you know recounting all of the
ballots by hand which is what a recount
is about that's a lot of work but you
know a statistical recount you might
have to look just 100 ballots or
something like that and then say yep
that's consistent you can stop there so
they can be very efficient because of
the statistics at all even for very very
large states or jurisdictions just
looking at a few belts you know we've
seen that already in the real world with
polling and things like that you know
statistical samples give you confidence
of the outcome so you take a random
sample you do some checking
you look at the random sample by hand
and not by the machine because you're
not trusting the machines here so you
look at the random sample by hand you
see well who won the sample but you may
also do some other computations as I'll
describe for checking how likely it is
that that sample is consistent with a
outcome that was announced maybe that
the sample is too small that you really
can't tell who won in the overall
election with much confidence from the
sample and so the overall lot it has a
higher higher level loop higher level
processes draw a sample check that
sample maybe the answer is draw more
make the sample larger so you might go
from 100 ballots to 200 ballots then you
check a 200 ballot sample and then maybe
you're done so there's many different
ways of doing this and part of it
depends with the kind of election you're
having so let's imagine we have a first
pass the post or a plurality election so
whoever gets the most votes wins and
they're the math is pretty simple and
we'd like to check whether a pile of
cast ballots
it's really consistent with the with the
announced outcome so we want to do an
audit how do I could we do that so let
me illustrate that with with this pile
here pile of cast bells for Alice or Bob
that's the whole election right so we've
got a this is a small County or
something that's only got 16 ballots so
you can imagine it's not sixteen but
sixteen hundred or sixteen million but
it's a big pile of paper and we don't
really want to look at all in order to
see who won but it's been announced that
Alice won and we want to check that does
that is that correct you can flip
through it and sort of look at CI is so
analysis or some Bob's and maybe she won
by 11 just 5 or 10 to 6 or something
like that there's some count we don't
need to verify the count as much as we
want to verify the winner really it does
if the counts off a little bit maybe
that doesn't matter so much it's
interesting but it's the real question
is who won the election and we have been
told that Alice won and we'd like to
check that we don't really trust the
person who counted or we where the loser
and bob is if we're told the bob loss or
bob and bob is distrustful of the
process he wants to have his people
participate with the election officials
and an audit and to confirm that yeah he
did lose the election or maybe he didn't
okay I don't we do an audit there's a
couple of ways of doing I'm gonna
describe one that's called the Bayesian
audit that was developed by a student of
mine Emily Shen myself but like most
audits it starts with a sample so we
could take a sample of the draw draw a
few samples let's take the know here's
one I'm just drawing that random here's
one and here's you choose some initial
size of the sample so there's our sample
that looks pretty much like it's an
alice win but that's just a sample and
who knows whether that's data to really
tell and it depends a bit on how close
the election is if it's a very close
election a small sample like this may
not be enough all right so what do we do
so we've got the sample we can see who
won the sample the truth of course is
who won in the whole pile not who won in
just the sample the sample could be
misleading sample could be too small the
sample might have too much of the losers
ballots so so we have to have some
process of figuring out what the whole
suite of the whole collection of ballots
might have looked like you sort of like
to do some unsampled
this sort of a funny notion but you'd
like to take the sample then
and expand it out in some way to look
like without having to look at the
balancing we only want to look at these
belts but it's the only looking at these
ballots
we'd like to unsampled which is to come
up with a prototype or an estimate of
what the whole set of belts might have
looked like and we can do that many
times so let's let's try that one so
here's a sample of for what what kind of
set of we had to what 16 ballots
altogether what set of 16 ballots might
there have been that could have produced
such a sample and so in a probabilistic
sense we're drawing from the posterior
we have a well-defined
distribution on the set of all possible
thanks but it's easy to describe this
it's beautiful technique do de pelea
called polies urn which allows you to
grow a sample to a larger thing that it
might have come from and so we do that
we pick one of these at random
Mississippi I happen to pick this one
pick one out and put two back ends so
I've got a sample of size four I'm going
to grow it up by 1/2 a sample of size 5
I'm gonna make a copy of whatever I drew
so here's baba put another Bob and I'll
write it in green so you know it's been
copied so now I've got a sample sample
of size 5 this isn't really a sample
from what came here it is sort of my
pulley as urn grown sample now it's
three to two well whatever but we had 16
originally so we want to repeat this
process so we draw another one a random
well maybe I drove off and Alice so put
another allison pick one out and put it
back together with a copy of it so now
i've got six balanced that's cool so now
I've grown it a bit so now now it's 4 2
2 and I can continue this process I pick
one at random
maybe I pick one with a copy it already
I copy that and put it in so you can see
how this would go let's go let's do this
so I've now got a 4 2 3 so I want to
grow up to 16 so I pick one at random
got an ALICE make a copy of Alice so at
the end of the arm process we've got 16
again and we could pretend like that's
the full the full cast out of cast spell
so we can see who won and so maybe Alice
won so we can put on our chart and say
Alice won that simulation these are
really simulation talisman 1 but there
was uncertainty there we could have
drawn cards in the
for an order and maybe gotten a
different result so we can imagine doing
the whole process again starting with
our four and growing it up to 16 so we
do that and we see who won and make it a
different set of ballots maybe maybe Bob
won that one okay so there's if it's
fairly evenly balanced at the beginning
you know bob is gonna win something else
is gonna win some and that's the key
here is you do a lot of simulations of
the sort on the one sample on the one
sample maybe alice wins lots of them Bob
wins some of them but maybe it's it's
fairly close you know so we'd like to
have 95% confidence so we made me want
Alice to win 95% of the runs here if she
doesn't win 95% we say the sample is not
big enough so we start over we don't
make the sample bigger maybe we draw
some more we go back we enlarge the
sample by drawing some more it's a new
sample is twice the size we said the
original one wasn't big enough so now
instead of growing from four belet's up
to 16 we're going from 8 to 16 and we
count see who wins and maybe this time
maybe this type me Alice wins them all
you know maybe since the samples bigger
now it's really pretty clear
mathematically from the sample that
alice is the winner
and so maybe she's winning them maybe
Bob wins one or two or something but you
know it's it's really overwhelmingly
clear that no matter how this gets
extended up I pull these urn you've got
Alice winning and so that's that's how
the audit might proceed you could say
well we grow the sample and this took
could be a pretty small sample by
comparison with the total set of cast
votes we might have a sample of size 100
and that's pretty small the computer can
do all this stuff fast so there's very
little examination of the paper ballots
I don't really care too much what
technique you use I really do think that
if we should have paper ballots and we
should be doing post-election audits
just to confirm that the anounced come
is really consistent with the paper
ballots those are two very important
properties we should have of all of the
elections everywhere in the u.s. or the
planet
get a receipt when you vote and the
receipt is not the plain text as to how
you voted but an encryption of how you
voted so it's something that you can't
sell down with the bar because it's not
something that's interpreted by somebody
else so a number or a barcode or
something like that and it represents
how you voted